[Music]
so thank you for inviting me today I'm
really excited to be here so you know
the title of my presentation probably
should say that I'm from an information
science school I'm a PhD candidate
graduated in June okay so the title of
my presentation is the making of
fungible opendata in biomedicine and
most of my presentation will be
dedicated to explain you the
socio-technical butters epistemic and of
societal challenges involved in using
genomic data and biomedicine research
genomic data but before going into that
I also wanna give you an overview a
short overview of my research values and
interests of my domain like influences
and methods they kind of informed my
research during my years as a PhD
student and then short overview of my
collaborative project because I have
done quite a lot in collaboration with
other departments so I'm going to point
out this project and then we don't give
you a lot of details probably more than
what you want to hear about my
dissertation project ok so since this is
a job talk I figured that I wanted you
to know who I am as a researcher what I
care about and why I want to be a
researcher in the first place because
you know with all the things that I
could do right now especially working
with data and people why do I want to be
a researcher right my main interest is
to reading epistemology since I have
memories have been really interested in
understanding how people make sense of
the world in different ways what kind of
means they use to make sense of the
world and why do we have all these
different perspectives and and now we
end up with different perspectives so
this is kind of what I always been
interested in too and that's also why I
probably have a master degree in
journalism so it's kind of curiosity
driven but then over the last seven
years
I really became interested in data
epistemologies most specifically and
code epistemologies and everything
started again seven years ago when I was
working as a journalist and also was
finishing my master in media studies and
during that time I witnessed the
widespread kind of sudden diffusion of
data and adoption of data-driven
techniques by trade and journalism it
was kind of a new thing back then and
and this was because the Italian
government back then it was kind of
inspired by the Obama's open data
initiative started to release all the
statistics and data and demographic and
transportation data about Italian cities
answer
so as journalists we were very
enthusiastic of how these especially I
was writing my master thesis which was
supposed to be on this topic so how to
use his statistics for storytelling and
myself I wrote some articles using API
is from Twitter and Facebook and you
know and talking about how then already
how the network back then was talking
about specific and understanding social
issues but then at some point I stopped
them and I stopped because I realized
that we really had no idea what we were
doing
so this journalist we had no training in
social science research methods we had
no conception of issues of validity
reliability generalizations bias in the
data we didn't know anything about these
things and I saw that some of us we were
using statistics to make kind of a big
claim that were not always you know back
the with good data section and then
especially it was particularly bothered
while by one event so the Italian
government was trying to pass this law
on sexual harassment on the phenomenon
of sexual harassment in Italy and and
some of the journalists they used some
public statistics to undermine this
phenomenon and showing that it wasn't
such a big thing as the people were
like you know pushing for this lot
faster we're saying that it was them so
at that point I decided to instead of
writing my dissertation about how to use
statistics for certainly what kind of
about the limits and how the statistics
so I became more interested in writing
about statistics than in using the type
of these data analysis myself from my
own storytelling if that makes sense
with you guys I think okay and that's
just when I realized that that's man of
each side in 2011 whatever that in our
data economy and information society
there are really three emerging groups
of people you know the data creators
those who consciously or unconsciously
couldn't produce all the data and
consciously like in social media got the
those who have the expertise to analyze
the data and those who have the means to
access and collect the data and and I
realized that as a researcher I was
interested in all these topics and you
will see at how issues of a pistol ology
data production but also a lot data
governance come up in my research across
all different projects so I was never
really able to focus just on one side so
it did kind of disturb them interceding
term yeah I guess I should also point
out I'm today a mainly a qualitative
researcher even though I have some
training in programming and statistics
and other types of research methods but
I'm mainly an ethnographer well we see
something more about it so influence is
the method I have a pretty
interdisciplinary background so I study
communication and then I have this
mastery Media Studies but over the you
know during my period as a PhD student I
think there are three main areas that
really impacted me as a researcher of
course information science and
classification theory maybe some of you
can recognize the cover of the book from
Barker and star so and my own advisor or
so
interests me a lotta Christine welcome
um without a lot of studies in
scientific collaborations and but also
social studies of data and algorithm
especially critical data studies that is
probably also feel that some of you are
familiar with the other thing is that
basically I like to say that I have a
minor in history of science history
science really and minor as a PhD
student even though it doesn't exist but
yeah so instead of science for me was
really really important in for in for my
work so much at UCLA we have a pretty
strong Department of history of science
people you know like that Porter that
like amazing people working there and
because my work is about how scientists
to use biology databases for me it was
impossible to make sense of this
phenomenon without looking at how you
know it evolved through time it was like
nearly impossible even though it was not
required to take more a historical
approach but this was really important
for me and the second thing is that
somehow it happened that a lot of my
work is related to issues of race which
was not something in the world to
necessary write about but then yeah I
just keep coming up everywhere so so I
also specialize in the history of human
variation and I'm particularly
interested in how the biomedical field
think about issues of race and issues of
biological determinism and that
everything will make sense eventually
hopefully you will see that I have a
disinterest okay am I talking too fast
[Music]
you know I have an accent
I tend to do it anyway okay so just a
short overview of my collaborative
projects I'd like to say that when I
join my department for the first time in
my life I felt that my brain was at home
I had this feeling that I wanted there
and I was surrounded by all these
amazing people they could just get what
I was interested into and especially my
PhD cohort was an amazing cohort you
were five or six of us and were all
interested in the same things I'm
writing about data and social issues and
so we collaborate a lot it was very
natural yeah it was not required at all
but it was a very fruitful type of a
collaborative environment so the first
event that we organized just after a few
months we started the project with this
hackathon event it was in 2000 early
2015 and in this specific event we
invited community members from the LA
area to come to this event and together
we downloaded and analyze different
publicly available datasets on police
officer homicide sir
a police officer involved a homicide so
our main question was to understand the
what type of informations were out there
and now accurate this information where
we divided our collaboration of few
groups I was reading the data mining to
a group we did some simple I mean not
maybe the simple depends on your skills
I guess querying of different data sets
and what I was because we had for
example one data set from the FBI that
was released from the FBI one dataset
collected by journalists one dataset
collected by community members and I was
very interested in seeing for a specific
time and place how these datasets were
reporting the occurrence of homicide
differently and I found some interesting
stuff that
have to talk about now but or I can talk
about this later or with you
individually then we organize another
event this was last year during
inauguration day you probably heard
about similar events around the country
this was done in connection in
collaboration with data refuge and a gym
so during this this day we invited this
was an archive atone house Ecole in
Sedona cotton and is very information
sciences type of intervention in this
case we had to nominate some data set so
that the were at risk of being deleted
during government transition because you
probably know when you change government
in the United States new governments
they all tend to the late content from
publicly from government websites and to
replace it with new content so we we
were very much interested in rescuing
and saving most content and data related
to climate change and and then I end up
ended up writing these these people with
a colleague of mine with Christine who
was a busy student and because I wanted
to know again this is my interesting
data government so that always come up I
want to know how this is possible in the
first place why there are no policies
that you know they protected these the
government websites from be completely
deleted do we have anything in place
that like kind of archives the type of
website somewhere beyond the Internet
archival and in the Gundam so we wrote
this paper together which we will
present next month two months okay but
my main secondary projector that this
was a continuously continuous
collaboration it's actually this project
which was done in collaboration with the
Institute for society and genetics at
UCLA
this part lab which is run by Chris
cultiva Sandra politics of science and
scientific collaborations I've been
joined this group probably my third by
second year so it's been a couple of
years that we analyzed and observed how
white nationalists understand and
interpret results from genetic ancestry
testing okay and particularly I was
particularly interested in seeing how
these white nationalists once they
receive results they are mixed up right
so they're not like 100% white how they
react to these digital results and how
they how they try to make sense of it
okay
and because my main dissertation project
is on open data I was interested in
seeing how data situates in between
different platforms because one thing
that they do which again you can ask me
questions laters is so they download the
raw data from the company's website why
because they're these companies like
23andme that they run the answer see
testing for you and then you can
download your raw data and you can
upload the raw data on third party
calculators and they recalculate the
date and they give you basically a
different result because it's also based
on the kind of reference populations
that they have their own samples and so
on and apparently turns out that these
alternative calculators they retrieve
whiter results for some reason that in
field really difficult to tell because a
black box them anyway so this was my
secondary project and okay so this was
kind of an overview of my collaborative
others but the main lab I've been
working on is the Center for knowledge
infrastructure system
I joined this Center right after you
know I started my PhD program and so
from day one I was a research assistant
with this lab and I started collecting
data at my research community really
early and I joined this grant that
basically funded my older
teach didn't - well not this year but my
first three years the grant is called if
the sharing is the answer what is the
question
and broadly investigates this current
trend and science policy that maybe you
are familiar with maybe not which is to
make available to the public to the old
international community and also to the
industry as much as possible
research data okay in our lab we have we
are like six researchers and each of us
we focus on a different discipline so
you have you know our colleague was
working on astronomy data colleague was
working on earth science and so on so
the idea is that eventually you know at
the end of the project to come together
in a comparison between how these issues
are different in different domains so my
specialization is in a genomic medicine
and I will tell you more about my
specific case study but before
presenting my research questions I
thought that I should give you some
background because it is a less
intuitive problem problem compared to
other things I wrote about you really
have to know what is going on okay
so first of all I am writing and I'm
talking about research data so these are
not clinical trial data
this is a research data that are
collected to answer specific research
questions and and I'm saying this
because I was at Hickam last week and
someone asked me what's the difference
between research data and social media
data there is no difference
understand why you want to focus on
research data as supposed to social
media data no it's like I think I'm very
interested in research data because
research data used for scientific
knowledge production which is a specific
type of knowledge production that comes
with specific expectations right so
scientific knowledge production is first
of all cumulative right we stand on the
shoulders of the Giants so it builds
upon itself and then is peer-reviewed
and is validated in a collaborative way
right so this is the main reason now one
of the main differences between research
data and other types of data then it's
publicly funded so at least the type of
data that I look at that's another
characteristic publicly funded so it's
an investment so it's the resource and
basically what's a commodity and then I
read this difference in a paper and I
found I thought it was interesting while
we can say that social media data found
the data research data crafted data so
this difference between crafted and
found crafted because again research
data collected to ask a specific
hypothesis also large-scale data set at
least in my community and you know with
the researchers that I work with not
maybe all research data but I believe
there is always an hypothesis in mind
and so what I was saying to ask right
and then within a specific experimental
setting and to ask specific research
questions okay and the second thing that
I want to introduce you is the open data
movement in science which is different
from the open data movement in
government example so biology and
biomedicine has a long history of data
sharing and reuse okay so biology has
been doing this for a long time and I
know because again I read a lot of books
about reactor but which helped me really
to characterize the new open data
movement so how is now different two
main reason reason so first
of all now making data publicly
available is becoming our requirement by
funding agency so if you want to collect
a new data set you have to again you
will see that this is specifically you
know what is going on in my case study
but if you want to collect data you have
to basically you know demonstrate that
you will make the data publicly
available while before like
traditionally the way biologists share
the data in second asuka I'm a biologist
I collect the data sector and then I
mine and analyze my data set at public I
publish a publication then along with
the publication I release my raw data or
some visual or some summary level data
along with my publication and then a bio
curator with this figure in biology
databases comes in and harvest the data
from the papers and from their open
repositories and then makes available
the data to the public so usually
traditionally data are released after
publication in the traditional you know
open movement and it's also very much
community driven so for now it's a human
being we will see but now it's actually
I believe he has I mean you never know
but by curators they play very important
roles so because they're usually there
are people that they know biology
anthologies really well so they have
this idea of how knowledge is
represented and organize them so the
harvest is summary level data from
publications and then the curated adding
metadata and ontological terms and
relationship and then you know the
uploading bioinformatics tools please
yeah so in my experience and I think
probably most of the cases by curators
they work for different platforms so you
know like databases they have their own
bio curators so maintain write the
platform and also harvest data from from
different publications and journals and
so used to be more community driven open
data in genomic medicine now it's more
like it's increasingly require there are
still a lot of scientists that do not
share their data but what I'm talking
about the new grants have been accepted
please all right funding bodies
funding bodies like funding agency yeah
yeah basically nature yes basically yeah
because I work with biomedical data so
my case study is an NIH funded group of
collaboration yes but I know that also
some private foundations are
increasingly requiring it but I mainly
work with publicly funded data
collections yeah
um let me think think is that my uh
medicine is kinda like 90% genomic right
now I think so yeah I would say there is
specifically genomic data for sure yeah
we see something more about it
but yes all data needs to be identified
my work is not that much about privacy
then they aren't identifications but
there is a lot of working that they are
showing that yes it identified but to
some extent that you can't read and that
D identify a DNA or someone so there is
a lot of research in that direction but
for sure these data are shared with
specific the identification techniques
even though as you will see my community
collects taste taste images from
children so that's impossible to
identify obviously I mean if that's how
do you do it so but yes there are a lot
of requirement are very careful with
privacy okay so now the idea is that you
know data are required to be sure but
also there is this push on making a data
available right after data collection
before publication before a scientist
before the data Creator herself can mind
and make sense of the data that yeah is
that when the data comes back from the
sequencing facility you have to make it
available or usually they give you six
months which is really not that much to
analyze a large-scale data set of
genomic data so why all this interest in
making this data available requiring to
make that available right after data
collection so I read a lot of you know
documents and grants and their different
reasons why different people wants to
push for this open data movement but I
think from the funding bodies the point
of view there is this idea of a fast
efficient science we want to make
research especially public research as
fascinated as efficient as possible so
if you have one large-scale data set and
I'm the person collected it I am the
only person with mining in to ask my own
research question they're not very
efficient
in an ideal situation you have to you
want to have ten other researchers who
at the same time why I am analyzing my
own data set they come in and ask
different research questions each of
them write different also from mine from
the same data set and it is the big
promise of open data in biomedicine the
idea that you can do that in a way that
can be like so the research process is
very efficient and you have returned on
a high return on investment right so
I've read up on the funders point of
view with many return on investment idea
but in order to do that you have to make
data for jabal which is not my
expression Archie Sabina Lyon LD in her
brand new book data-driven biology she
talks about this move of making biology
data for enjoyable data more from econ
but you probably recognize that is an
economics term and which basically means
that you have to have this data turn
into some commodities that that are
interchangeable and they speak for
themselves so you have to make this it
in a way that anyone can come and the
Trust is data and mind is Theta even
though this researcher did not witness
the collection of the data in the first
place so this is so how do you do it you
either try to make them context-free or
as a venal dinelli thing you have to
package the data set in a way that can
travel and can go into this journey
between different research situations so
this idea of data packages okay and I
think I said enough about
ok so these are my main three rich
research question mediclaim
when I was reviewing all this literature
and I got very much interested into
figuring out or what's going on with all
this open data movement I realized that
there was I couldn't find that really a
paper that was one paper that was
describing how people were using this
data so it's all about right now it's a
lot about the prime minister of you know
open data and how do we make this data
to speak for themself and all these
things but I couldn't find a description
of typology or characterization of the
actual practices of reusing this data so
you know I went into my field and I
started asking people and observing them
how are you actually using open data
that you did not collect yourself for
your own research that's kind of my main
research question the first one and then
I wanted to see because the specific in
this community is kind of a new
phenomenon to make all this data
available I want to see all these
policies and this transition from
requirement free publication data
sharing is changing the way researchers
they do their you know research
practices and then and then I figure out
though that these data were reused a lot
outside academia and outside the medical
field and I found it fascinating and
this data were collected to ask
biomedical questions and then they were
used in top in context that didn't have
anything to do with biomedicine so I
added this chapter to my dissertation
which I don't have much time to talk
about I wanted to tell you everything
about everything but that's not not
doable so I'm gonna give you an overview
of what is my thought right now about
the first two research questions mainly
okay let me introduce you to my
community so this is an NIH funded
consortium
there are around 15 lobster involved
there
graphically distributed around the
United States and also they have some
collaboration in other states but I
visited the six of these labs so the
goal of these researchers and their
funding to collect and make completely
publicly available of course with some
privacy so there are you know we have to
be to have an IRB if you want to use the
data for research also make completely
available prior to publication right
after data collection so you know the
data comes back from the sequencing
facility you do some quality control and
then you have to make it available and
they call these data collections
themselves hypothesis free genomic data
which I yeah I don't think it's video
for this is free and then you know by
talking bit and they actually are aware
of it this is high throughput data
because it's collected with next
sequencing technologies and so on some
data types are not going to explain you
today the difference between these data
type is about whole genome sequencing
expression data from chip seek and Aaron
ethic experiments if you're familiar
with it microarrays all microarrays
but especially the most reuse the data
types are genome genotypes and
phenotypes from g1 studies the genomic
wide Association studies and I will tell
you something more about this specific
one this is a community that is very
interesting for me because it's very
interdisciplinary so I talk with
computational biologists the web wet lab
biologists developmental biologists
human geneticist surgeon surgeons and I
think that's also why to some extent I
think my findings can be generalized to
conduct the research biomedical research
environment today because you have all
these different disciplinary
configurations okay so do you want
studies so the main idea of G was
studies to collect
large-scale data set of genotypes so
genes data sequence data and phenotypes
you know like image is mainly in this
case and images of the face so how does
it over collected them DNA samples and
images from the face were collected from
over 3,000 Caucasian children and then
the DNA was the fan was genotype for
specific snips for specific genetic
mutations that they the word you know
known to be connected to fish all the
morphology and then the fish face images
were studied to extract metrics so
landmarks and metrics and that can be
used to quantify the face and then of
course everything was made available and
the idea was to you know for everybody
to combine the data to find a
correlation between the mutation in the
genome and specific facial features the
thing about this data set is that this
database them which which is called a 3d
facial norms database is that it was
highly reusing connection in a network
way in connection with other databases
in the water they have different
populations like you know population
front and Vanya was used a population
form so different type of ethnicities or
as they say populations were using
connection with each data set so the
important thing to understand is that
the researchers who collected this data
they do research in the biomedical area
like all of them literally all of them
no no damn collective desire to do
anything else then conducting research
in what is called a craniofacial
research so they deal with real rare
syndromes that are expressed at birth in
the face I didn't want to capitalize by
using an image of a child with a chronic
facial birth defect ok so I show you
this poster from this movie because
tells the story of one of these children
with one of these
one of these the syndromes some so this
is the context in which the data are
collected and what the researchers write
about them this is one example of how
you can extract some metrics from
official imager and you can understand
that it's probably not difficult for you
to imagine how this data can be reused
in all sort of ways once you quantify
the piece of body and is such an
important piece of our body right if the
main way we express our identities it
can be used in a sort of way it is just
obviously stupid after that wants to
give you you know your ancestry profile
based on your facial metrics so what
difficult to tell it's kind of the same
idea but I was showing an example that
is drawn from the same data and is it
just I found it and I thought he could
like I mean it reminds me a lot also
this one I don't know if it's wrong from
the same idea but I know that the they
were the first term to really quantify
the face and developed this new really
accurate matrix so I know that these
metrics are used a lot and now would
assume that probably yes certain
landmarks and metrics they are very
accurate so they couldn't be used in no
sort of ways but probably the most
problematic in my opinion way in which
this data was reused was to develop
forensic DNA DNA phenotyping techniques
which are now if you're familiar with
maybe you heard about this before by
this idea of collecting some DNA from a
crime scene and then reconstruct the the
face of the suspect or digitally and
computationally and and well I know that
the research that comes out from this
collaboration between in between ah you
know it was integrated with other data
databases in a network way and all these
things but informed the development of
some prototypes for this type of
research and this is what the last
chapter on my dissertation is about so
just to give you an idea of you know
what is the volume in this data that I
look at and in the scientific practices
okay so just a few words about my
research I might add them I don't want
to use too much time to talk about this
you can ask me questions later
I collected over 50 interviews with
these populations i spanned over 200
days in between these labs may be mine
is not a traditional ethnography in the
sense that i didn't spend time at one
site is more base of interviews but you
know i spend the front two to four weeks
at each lab though so i had the
opportunity to see all the data
collection how it happened and then i
you know read and analyze a lot of
documents and things okay so just to
remind you we thought your questions
were about so my main goal is to
possible to understand how the
scientists are reusing this data so
these are use practice system so the
main so first of all i immediately
notice that scientists when they were
talking about their other user data and
when i post these questions they were
referring to different things so some of
them they will give me some answer
didn't have anything to do with some
other answers and it took me a long time
for me to come up with a typology with a
characterization of the different
practices because it's not clear there
is not a language to talk about it so my
first goal was to give them and myself a
language to talk about what do you mean
when you talk about data reuse so one
distinction that was keep coming up was
between what i eventually called
background reuse of data and foreground
reuse of data so background the use of
data refers to this traditional way that
i already described to you of reusing
each other data which means that these
are data that are access
from their shared the first of all along
with the publication there accessed on
Bioman by informatics tools and they're
used for contextualization and mainly
they're visualized them so so yeah so
this is kind of the main idea is these
are two databases that are used a lot by
the researchers I talked with and also
outside the craniofacial community one
is the Armeen data set the other one is
the genome browser I probably heard
about it's a very popular tool and the
way scientists reuse these platforms
daily so it's a very common practice
they mainly go on these platforms and
I'm you know the type of the name of the
gene they want to retrieve all the
information that is known on so this is
known knowledge and then they've through
this visualization to access this
validated set of knowledge around
specific biological entities so they use
it to set up their experiments so before
conducting an experiment or to interpret
the statistical findings really all
preliminary findings from experimental
practice I suppose to four grams we use
them so for grantee use is where all the
promise about open data takes place it's
about running secondary data analysis of
others raw data okay we all know the raw
data is and simran but I mean a low
process data okay so this is these are
these like different practice comes with
a set of completely different deals so
while for whenever the access other's
data for the background you use the
access data that is known and works as a
reference to whenever you go and you
want to mine someone else raw data it's
more about knowledge discovering the
potential of the raw data set is unknown
right so you don't know what you're
going to find
also because remember
as I was telling you all this data was
collected was made available prior to
publication so not even a data creator
knows what she can find in the data so
everything is collected in the potential
is unknown this is kind of unexplored
data and while data used for background
are highly trusted by the community
later used for foreground researchers
were expressing a lot of concerns over
the quality of this data mainly because
I didn't have an historical kind of
record that comes with it I didn't have
a reputation you know everything was
really kind of unknown so for Gondry us
there is a very emerging practice while
researchers access other's data in an
integrated and visualized way on
bioinformatics tools every day whenever
was asking ok when was the last time you
actually reused reanalyzed someone as
raw data it was you know most it was
really rare so it's a very emerging
practice even though it cost it you it
officially constitute the real promise
of open data movement ok and I think I
said everything I wanted to say about
this more or less yes
they probably already done a lot of
processing well yeah this either also
the question that I was wondering right
yes so the main incentive I think
especially in this collaboration the
shearing came as a package with a
collection so the idea was to collect
these hypothesis free data the problem
is that obtaining a grant from NIH to
collect I potus's free data is really
difficult because you have to show you
know there are one user you have to show
that you have a specific research type
of trajectory so the idea was like okay
we're gonna give you the funding to
collect this larger data set but in
return you have to make everything
available after publication I think no
it's very day listing like it's exactly
what your since this idea just because
it's a lot it means that everybody can
come we should like make it like super
efficient right yeah it's kind of ideal
practice but then as you were saying the
social incentives they're not much there
so but I would say a little bit more of
how design visitor actually reused
because well thank you for that question
I think is that when I talk with the
researchers I found a big disconnect in
the way they describe this practice of
running second the data analysis in a
hypothetical way and how they actually
do it and because it is social media
collective I created a little meme for
you guys thank you for getting it was a
little worried I don't mean steal a
thing
no it's kind of feels tweet dated but
anyway the intention okay so the ideal
practice in which you know people that
describe around is secondary analysis
they are like yeah so I go on someone
else database they download the raw data
and I rely on the analyze data to ask my
own research questions and I'm like okay
when was the last time you did it but
like well I don't actually do it but
someone else does it okay talk with
someone who is doing it and like you
know and it wouldn't like happen in that
match but I knew that they were really
analyzing other's data so what like can
you please tell me exactly how you do it
and it turns out that this specific
community at least really values the
collaboration with a data creator and
when they reanalyzed someone has raw
data so what they do they literally
collapse the data a person crazy data
and we dispersed so then negotiate the
way that is accessed and reused so the
community really value this
collaboration with the data creators and
the Terr users and in my citation
chapter I am I then asked a lot of
questions once I realized this which
took a while of how ecstatic I started
this collaboration is so important and
is for many reasons that I don't have
time me to describe all of them but just
kind of faster so yeah it allowed for
skills and knowledge integrations
because most of the data sets are
collected by qualitative sorry by wet
lab biologist er that they have a great
understanding of the biological
functions behind the data collection but
mostly computational biologist runs
secondary data analysis so by
collaborating with each other they can
integrate the skills it's also a matter
of version control because when you
deposit a data set you deposit this data
set with all the known knowledge
annotation data metadata that you know
about the data set at the time
in which you deposited but as a feel
angry was saying datasets are living
things so the more they the data creator
works with the data set the more she
understands things about it so if you
contacted a detect Lito directory you
know you have the most up-to-date
version of the data set and know the
information and variables that goes with
it it also helps for faster access to
protected data we will send out these
issues of privacy and if you join
someone else IRB you probably in heard
about this before is it's much easier
especially if you asking similar
questions and obtaining your own iron
beam so that's another reason why
especially to download data from some
platforms it's it's faster to do this
and it also kind of encourages to
develop trust in this high-throughput
data and explore data because the
refutation of the data creator kind of
works as a substitute for the lack of
reputation of the data set itself and
but then maybe most importantly it helps
scientists to deal with issues of credit
attribution because most of these
secondary analysis they end up in court
or Shipton so what happen is that you
receive both the data creator and the
data collector receive credit together
for the secondary data analysis another
thing I didn't have much time to talk
about but it's a big issue of credit
attribution invisible label because so
it is easier when you hear P I is saying
so this a little provocation saying oh
yes all data should be made openly
available right now too bad that the
people who collect the data usually
postdocs and if you try to be a postdoc
in biology today it's really hard the
postdocs I took with to the web postdocs
for seven eight years I was really hard
and all they have are their data like
nothing else so for the PI's of course
yeah yeah I mean let's make everything
available for the postdoc is like that's
not exactly that
easy yeah and there are other issues of
invisible labor but you can talk about
this data some so we're all of these
lives asked them so I thought a lot
about all these kind of tensions that
are going on this open data movement and
I think that what I'm witnessing is is
the like the competitions of two
different like view of what Sciences
should look like some one side you have
this idea of data they have to speak for
themselves and there is all these push
especially in the informatics community
to curate the data in a way that you
create a separation between the data
creator and the data user so it's
actually seen as a bad thing like the
fact that you have to call someone Apple
to use their data absolutely a bad thing
it's like a stigmatized yeah you
shouldn't be able to do that why you
shouldn't be able to do this anyway and
then there is some funders that they
have this funniest strategy that is
centered on the collecting new data
macabre see Nadal available which leads
to all these issues of competition and
rush to data reuse and then also these
problems of invisible labor and
workforce the other side you have people
they understand the science data science
model as a collaborative practice where
knowledge validation not just knowledge
production is understood as something
that we do it together really like this
idea of which probably someone has wrote
of already of objectivity as a
collaborative practice really like to
think about this and then well where
data creators they contribute to the
secondary analysis of the raw datum
where the funding is about bringing
people together not just about bringing
data together and also where data
creators and data users they receive
credit for their work so the end up in
quarters so with our lumber the
Center for knowledge infrastructures
they thought a lot about interventions
because ok we write about all these nice
things but then no we
work with the scientists and we want to
help so we like to think about ourself
as some sort of mediators between the
different visions of science and that's
why we organize the opportunity to bring
together people there are some workshops
users and in my specific community I
would like to organize a hackathon event
and my dear for a hackathon event in
this case is where you have the data
creators that they present their own
data sets and you like deal with issues
of cry distribution and also how these
data set the can videos and I really
think that could be really valuable to
have the people who collect the data in
the event itself ok so how to build
these monstrous dissertation have three
main papers that I want to write one is
the cold like my father how i met your
datum thank you for getting diesel so so
the role of data creator and we user
collaboration in reuse in open data then
a science policy paper which is the
making a fungible open data winner and
losers in a fast science and then I have
asked yes the more kind of this one is
more about this yes exactly like what
kind of competing views yes I mean not
just about their postdocs the but I
guess of so format because I think that
increasingly people who have a greater
understanding of the biology but maybe a
lack of computational skills that will
be set back by this model of science and
then STS Journal paper which is mostly
about my third chapter that didn't have
time to talk about today which is this
idea of how do you create a collected
data in a biomedical context and then we
use them to something completely
different and this type of work is
especially related to issues of race
because at least so far my understanding
is that it really didn't have any
meaningful there was not really a reason
on having different ethnicities to
investigate this syndrome so so while
race becomes important when you want to
reuse it outside the biomedical field to
develop all these technologies so at
what point race becomes important
basically as a concept and then because
I read a lot about the history of
facial medicine but also on the
quantification of the face and this is a
history that is related with the history
of human variation and biological
determinism and race and data fication
of the body and all these things have
this idea which right now of course is
kind of up in the air because I'm
writing my dissertation or writing a
book that potentially could be called
data face how the human face became a
quantifiable commodity so I'm like tell
all these stories about all these
different like perspectives on the face
like yeah they came to be together and
how they intersect to eventually have a
quantifiable commodity that is our face
and
[Applause]
so they main use it I'm investigating is
this what was it these forensic DNA
phenotyping techniques but these data
were used in a sort of ways the other
thing was it used it is used a lot to
develop technologies and tools devices
related to the face like headphones
design and you know glasses design but
another very interesting application is
for the automation of diagnosis for rare
syndromes so the someone else in
actually in Israel they developed this
after that doctors they can use in
remote places but I don't have access to
the literature and they can with this
app take a picture of the child that
potentially know has a craniofacial
abnormalities syndrome and then the
Apple retrieves a list of potential
syndromes related to this specific
phenotype there was another very
interesting application of this data but
the one that fascinated me the most was
probably this DNA phenotyping thing so
yeah in this case the knowledge behind
the development of these technologies
was developed by a lab that collaborated
with the labs and leaders were say with
the data creators themselves so the
people who collected the data were not
really interested in actually issues of
race and because the whole point of DNA
phenotype in is dividing people by race
right so that's the whole point because
that's what they want to do to say ok
you are from this this that population
it's mainly also because it doesn't give
you so many details that you can
actually identify one person this is
like a kind of a generic representation
and so what we saying right so the data
creators they were not conducting this
research at at all but they collaborated
with different labs and that developed
this type of knowledge that then was
used and then informed the design of
these technologies so there are some
startups in New York who are doing this
and their main clients are police
stations police officers and I saw some
of them and some talks and actually one
of the data creators one of the labs
that collected this type of data one of
the post Doc's she gave this talk where
she basically explained that you can't
do this that makes that not much sense
from a scientific point of view and she
was in in her study she basically did
not find a correlation between certain
metrics and ethnicity groups and then
there were some you know police officers
in the room they were asking question
about it so how so should we trust the
technology or no so it is used right now
a red couple of articles that it was
used in some trials but he still you
know very merging is not sort of
validated like DNA things and even
though so DNA actually comes with sort
of problems but and young there is one
author she's in Europe and Amsterdam
Amanda Charak that she is writing about
these specific issues and yeah my work
is very much informed of my hair work
she's anthropologist
the data creator data reuse or
relationship that you found difference
what their different sorts of
institutions like I can imagine it's
easier to pick up the phone and have a
conversation if it's like two biologists
that working probably funded
universities on opposite coasts but what
about when it's a the data creator is a
biologist a research university every
user is so I think okay one thing I can
think about it depends let's first talk
about in in a university context in the
Kadeem iam the main challenge is between
people who conducts the research on
animal models and people who conduct the
research on humans because I have to
translate each other knowledge but also
because they have different types of
access so if you work on dog if your lab
mainly does research with mice and you
know super efficient or whatever all
animal models you can't really have
access to human protected data so they
want to collaborate but then they have
to do sort of institutional requirements
so I think that's mainly it but if you
are a researcher I think usually it's
not that difficult to collaborate I
don't think about any other
institutional challenge' so the funny
thing is that with human protective data
you probably heard about this before if
you want to reuse research data for a
publication for an academic publication
you have to have a higher be right but
IRB is for academic work if you want to
reuse it for commercial purposes you
have to guarantee that you are using
anonymized way you have some
requirements but you don't even need an
IRB actually because IRB just for
academic publications so and so the way
it work the based on my observations in
the specific case study is that again
you have one research lab collecting the
data
then you have all these mediators labs
that were not really involved but
they're still on a research university
who reuse this data to develop some
knowledge and then these researchers I
think the work as a consultant for
private companies so you have yes that's
why exactly no follow the date on you
will see but what's going on so that's
kind of how it moves on and then the
other important thing to remember is
that is always used in a network way
because if you have one that I said we
just Caucasian people would be useful so
then is highly integrated with datasets
from Europe and I write the other thing
that's nothing that they do right and
postdocs around so there was this
postdoc participating the collection of
data said that on a different population
in Europe and then she's now working now
but I collected this data so then they
can integrate each other date on when
these things and then some other said
datasets are in Saudi Arabia and so it's
a kind of a natural type of way but yes
one thing that I'm I want to do is you
know indeed like trace exactly how these
days I moved around there was like
integrated in between different
resources so there is not one way of
doing it I feel like there are all these
little steps that you do when you know
people they don't just kind of concern
our collaborative like a natural way
it's not like they have a master plan
how are they that is there an emergency
is there this is very interesting and
it's fun to see that I want to look into
I'm not at that point yet but it's
definitely I know that in biomedicine
you have certain ways to define
populations right they're called
population and turns off they saying the
biomedical research usually you don't
use the term like race right you don't
call it race at all you call it
populations and I would say yeah they
use the name of the place weight was
collected like the New Jersey population
and it's real permission amsterdam
population that tanzania population but
would be interesting to see if there are
some variation in the language for sure
it's definitely one thing I will look
into yeah and also if it changes when
you know you're using a different
context but yeah
I see okay okay yeah so one passage that
maybe I was in 100% clear about inside
so there is a difference between the
research data that are used to develop
the technologies to the knowledge
influence the technologies and the
reference data that's used by police
officers so the research data is all the
data that I look into but then police
officers they use this data in
connection with their own reference
databases so they don't use the nor use
their research data directly I really
hope they're not doing be kind of crazy
if they also because the research
datasets are about children images so
those informed the knowledge that then
is used to develop technologies but then
they are the reference data sets are you
know data sets collected from all of us
ideas and driver license they are like
data sets from like population so
another theme that you know I read about
is this problem that then they developed
this profile this picture profile and
then is run against the data set so
police officer that I said they are
really biased in themselves so you have
these issues of bias that they keep like
building out
or in it just it is cited because at
least for the data said that look at
usually they say that's actually how I
found find out about this right actually
found out because someone came I'm gonna
start doing this research some all from
the community I think this interesting
came to me and told me well but do you
know how these data are used that you
should write about this because I think
this is problematic and then and that's
it the hold information that I had so my
journalistic I was really happy you an
ethnographer and then so what I did I
did express in that I want to look all
the publications and they look for all
the publication that side this
consortium and then how that's how I
find out the question I thought was can
you tell when you use basis to you
before pizza but yeah I know they're
producing a tandem substa so they con
the consortium is both about the
collection of the data and make them
available so you know if you down if you
use data from a faith-based consortium
you have a list of people there who
collect the data
who are these kind of facial researchers
doing research on rare syndromes
right no yeah no that's great service
that's a great question so I think that
maybe got lost during this process is
that actually this data did the face
base concert so mainly the idea is to
make that available raw level or a low
process level so they do not have many
visualizations tools so mostly the idea
is to reuse data for foreground in this
specific community so but the fact is
that that was also for me confusing at
the beginning because I was asking them
so how do you use other sit down and
they were describing to me
background views but they were supposed
to do foreground reuse so that's why we
did the language tonight distinguish
these practices because I was asking
something they were answering something
else' it was so confusing at the
beginning so yeah thank you but I know
this is like kind of all the you know
winder somehow thank you
[Applause]